et notre nouvelle recrue est au taquet
et l'afl bourret café mais ça devrait
c'est quoi le fait souvent rire
on y va
captain america monsieur lang je suis
très honoré de vous rencontrer
il faut peut-être que je vous lâche ham
1-3 c'est incroyable captain america ah
ouais moi aussi je vous reconnais
comment dire je sais que vous avez pas
mal de relations
je suis très flatté que vous ayez pensé
revoir ça commence à avoir un tic tac
oui ça va je m'excuse pour la dernière
fois à passer le test mais ça se
reproduira pas on vous a expliqué contre
11 pas au chaos et parlé d'un disque un
nom d'auteur et on est hors la loi cette
fois en venant avec moi vous l'accepter
si c'est ça j'ai l'habitude